hey everyone it's sarah thredson are
sorry and calm and today we're going to
talk about crutches and as always when
you get done watching this review you
can access the free quiz that will test
you on this assistive device so let's
get started for exams in nursing school
you want to make sure that you are
familiar with assistive devices such as
crutches canes and walkers and in our
next videos we will be talking about
canes and walkers
so with crutches what you specifically
want to know for exams is how they
should properly fit the different types
of gates you can do with crutches how a
patient should go up and down the stairs
with crutches and how they should get up
or set down in a chair so first let's
talk about proper fit what are some
things that you need to see in your
patient that tells you that those
crutches fit them properly well before a
patient even starts using crutches the
crutches will have to be adjusted based
on the patient's height and they can be
adjusted at the bottom and at the top
and usually on most crutches there's a
height range where you will slide the
part of the crutch to meet whatever your
patient's hype is also there's a hand
grip on the crutch that can be adjusted
as well so some things you want to
remember is that you want to be looking
at the gap between the crutch rest pad
and axilla the armpit there should be a
gap there it should be about two to
three fingers width which ends up being
about one to one and a half inches and
the reason you want this gap is because
while the patient is using using the
crutch they need to be putting all their
weight on the hand grips rather than on
this crutch rest pad via maxilla area
because in this area you have nerves and
if they're putting all their weight on
that number one it's really gonna be
uncomfortable and hurt but it's also
gonna damage those nerves in that area
also you want to be looking at the hand
grips and where they're lining up on the
body the hand grips should be even with
the top of the hip line so whenever the
patient actually uses
the handgrips their elbow will be
slightly bent at about 30 degrees now
let's talk about the different types of
gates while using crutches and you want
to make sure that you really truly
understand these different types of
gates that I'm going to go over because
exams love to give you a description of
a gate that a patient may be doing while
using crutches and you'll have to
identify it so before a patient even
starts ambulating with crutches at first
you want to make sure that they are
wearing a gait belt for safety also
before they start doing one of these
type of gates they're going to start in
the tripod position and it looks
something like this and it forms like a
triangle Hintz looks like a tripod and
this is where the crutches are about 6
inches out diagonally from the feet so
first let's start out with the point
gates we have three of them we have the
2-point gate the 3-point gate and the
four point eight now how you can keep
these straight is that you need to ask
yourself how many points are on the
ground hence how many crutches are on
the ground and how many feet are on the
ground whenever you're looking at the
scenario because each crutch counts as a
point and each foot counts as a point so
the two point we're gonna have two
points on the ground at a time whether
it's a crutch or a foot so what does it
look like well this is where the patient
will move the crutch on the injured side
so we're gonna say it's the right side
so they move the right crutch and they
move the left foot together then they
will move the left crutch on that non
injured side and the right foot together
so you have two points
next is the four-point game and it's a
little bit similar to the two-point gait
but each point is moving separately
because remember in two-point they were
moving together the Rye and the left
moving together and then the left and
the right moving together but here with
four point they're separate so the
patient will move the right crutch
witches will say the injured side then
they'll move the left foot then they'll
move the left crutch and then they'll
move the right foot
and the last point gay is the 3.8 and
this is where they move both crutches
and the injured leg together at the same
time and then they will move the non
injured leg
and then lastly we have the two swing
gates and it's either a swing to gate or
a swing through gate and let the names
help you so the swing to gate is where
the patient will move both crutches
forward then they will hint swing or
move both legs forward and place them at
the placement of where the crutches are
located
now the swing through
is very similar to this they will move
both crutches forward then they will
move both legs forward can't swing both
legs forward but they will swing it pass
the crutch placement
now let's talk about stairs how does a
patient navigate up and down the stairs
while using crutches well you want to
keep these two straight and what I'm
meaning is which leg is going to go
first up the step versus which leg is
going to go down the step first and to
remember that remember good up and bad
down
so whenever a patient is going up the
stairs their good leg is going to go
first up on the step followed by the
crutches and the bad leg which will
proceed and go up the step
now whenever they're going down the
steps they're going to move the crutches
down onto the stab that will help
provide stability followed by the bad
leg because a bad leg is going to go
down and then they're going to move the
good leg down on to the step
and lastly we're going to wrap up the
lecture and talk about how a patient
sits down and gets up while using
crutches
to sit in the chair the patient's going
to back up to the chair and fill the
chair with the non injured leg and when
the patient fills the chair with a non
injured leg they're gonna stop and move
both crutches over to the injured side
for support then the patient's going to
grip the hand grips and slightly bend
the non injured leg and feel behind them
and then set in the chair while keeping
the injured leg extended to get up from
the chair the patient is going to take
the crutches and put them on the injured
side for support he's going to keep the
injured leg extended and push up on the
non injured side and using the hand
grips of the crutches then he's going to
put the crutches in position thank you
so much for watching don't forget to
take the free quiz and to subscribe to
our channel for more videos